you I guess speaking of industry plants
and industry in cells Russ my main well
you're about to say Russell Russell is
an in cell bro he's a multi-platinum
recording in cell I was like this is the
most confident five three dude he said
so I did like a he did an interview on
shade four or five or whatever no of The
Breakfast Club the other Breakfast Club
yeah
and he's likely Charlemagne's asking
them about you know young bands and
smoke purp like continually clown him on
Twitter yeah
Young Band specifically yeah so I think
Charlamagne brought those two up I
didn't see the whole clip I want so okay
okay so yeah you like he like he brings
it up and then he brings up you know
rappers saying like [ __ ] Russ and that
and Russ goes on this like very stuttery
like long rant about like well I said
they I've seen him in person you know
what time it is they know what time it
is bro they know what time it is though
so what does that mean like did you he's
like they know what time it is you know
what yeah well yeah that's 4:30 yeah
they know what time it is so you know
forward well 4:24 p.m. all I must say is
I got like he starts bragging about
having footage of smoke purp getting
jumped ya know one of the two oh yeah
yeah one of the two and then young bands
tweeted you know damn well Russ ain't
beat my ass applied to the video yeah
you know damn well he's like [ __ ] Russ a
smoke herb didn't say anything no
breasts said if if they say [ __ ] Russ
one more time that's watching the video
yeah so in young fans responded by just
going [ __ ] Ross you know damn willing to
beat my ass
so then today academics put up a video
of smoke perv actually getting jumped
and it's whack like the jumping isn't
even like that solid they got some shots
in there but I'm like these are your
shooters bro Devo I mean security does
nothing
that's so English that's so English just
stubborn and like well nothing in my
contract says I have to get in a way of
these so long if you really if you
really want me to do this law only my
supervisor to call me on my line and
then and then I'll get it authorized and
then I speak to the head of security and
then if he says it's okay so it's like
two layers before we could properly like
intervene oh [ __ ] they've already uh
Club these little cheeks so I guess it's
over and this little cheeks and guess
it's over then well sorry sorry move
along there like one of them is like
hugging perp
like like they do kind of beat the [ __ ]
out of them I mean they beat his ass but
like it's just kind of like come on like
Russ wasn't even there that's my mom and
then the follow-up live with the rest
and they were like you know you don't
keep talking behind his eight people if
you only keep talking you don't keep
talking I'm trying to look over his
bouncers shoulders yeah you keep talking
like honest tippy-toes what's that now
yeah [ __ ] yellow let all them dudes
move out the way to say all that [ __ ]
yeah you won't yeah I know so wack I
know it's wack to go on a radio show and
brag about the fact that your goons beat
up it didn't he just criminate himself a
little bit like I mean what was funny
was I guess Charlamagne at some point I
interview brought up something about
like suing or like pressing charges and
Russ goes like they won't do that
because that's not hip-hop star let me
go see yeah they will yeah well this
error doesn't care about stuff like that
yeah they will and then like dude you're
not hip-hop yeah Russ goes like well
whatever that's wack then that's your
back and you could feel it I felt like
for a moment he felt like always oh [ __ ]
yo did I just tell him myself yo like
Charlamagne
like if you would like edit that part
out oh damn no that really good know
like like I know like I didn't like I
didn't know like no you think I'll press
charges you really think so yeah yeah
this generation don't care about that
and you can't hit that bar down
[Laughter]
then DJ and me so what so what so what
the new he's always screaming he's
always away from his might yelling tell
us about that was about that time got a
booty Nash Russ was on the [ __ ]
Forbes list though for most money and
hip-hop made last year or this year I
guess yeah twelve million bucks hey man
it's all like fortnight kids and college
girls buying this [ __ ] I just think
that's that's pretty crazy yeah I mean
it doesn't surprise me
let's see who else is on this thing he's
still looking this up he's still in sale
though bucks no I mean no he probably is
I mean he's like he's got money and all
that he's so funny
he's so funny if he didn't [ __ ] like
okay like I'm not like laughing at
insults just saying I'm just saying like
if he had all that yeah if if he liked
the money in the fame and he's confident
and he stays making like romantic songs
about sex or whatever no he would like
no girls no he'd be hitting bang
the Insull philosophy which is you can
literally have it all it's a little dude
yeah and it doesn't matter yeah yeah
yeah the five three Ness just go away
yeah the short people slander
it's crazy wild I was like if I was like
Russell sighing I would be legitimately
so self-conscious about that I got on it
right now I got all that [ __ ] in like
high school and junior high and I
thought it was done with and now net now
you know what it feels like it feels
like um whenever I read those tweets
it's like when the teacher gets the like
the teacher gets in front of the class
and I'm like alright so this test was
really bad there were only ten passing
grades and I'm gonna hand them out right
now and then it like when I see I when I
read the five I'm like and I like open
one eye is eight oh my god like when I
read it sweet I feel like I'm about to
like just get
bad F like I can just take a huge L as
I'm reading it go as soon as I know
you're one inch away but not take a nail
yeah I'm like whoo I got a b-plus on
that [ __ ] so happy yeah oh God if they
would have said five nine how would I be
just in shambles right now kill myself
instantly okay this is the tweet I went
out with my 5-1 friend and her 5-2
boyfriend on Sunday and it was like
walking two Pomeranians it's so [ __ ]
it's just it's wack
[Music]
[Music]
is that